هنا محطه قطارات العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
او محطه الصمود كما وصفها الاوكران بعد
الحرب دخلت سجل التاريخ الروسي لذاكره
الحرب واجهه الصواريخ من كل جانب لكن
حركتها لم تتوقف
ظلت تنقل النازح من خط النار الى المناطق
الامنه وتاخذ
المتطوعين من مراكز التدريب العسكريه الى
خط النار
كان عند اغلاق الموانئ الاوكرانيه تقوم
بنقل القمح
شيدت هذه المحطه قبل بيئه و23 عاما
واقول لقت بشكل مؤقت اكثر من 300 مره منذ
فبراير الماضي اجراء احترازي من السلطات
الاوكرانيه
الشبكه التي كانت تغطي كل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ب 100 الرحلات اليوميه اقتصرت
بسبب الحرب
واخرجت عددا من المدن شرقيه البلاد من
التغطيه بطبيعه الحال المدن التي ضمتها
روسيا مؤخرا اما خارجيا فقد اقتصرت على
بولندا وفينا وبخاريست
[موسيقى]
عندما تقف امام لوحه الاعلانات يفاجئك عدد
الرحلات اليوميه الى مختلف المدن
الاوكرانيه في الغرب والجنوب والشمال لكن
المدهش ان الحيويه التي تشهدها في المحطه
ليست هي الطاقه القصوى لحركه القطارات في
وقت السلك حيث تلامس الرحلات عتبه الف
رحله يوميه في مختلف المسارات المحطه التي
يتجاوز عدد مسارات السكك الحديديه فيها
اكثر من سبعه عشر مساء ما زالت تعمل بشكل
انتقالي من خلال اصدار التذاكر وتوجيه
الركاب الا ان الامر قد يتوقف فجاه عند
تعطل الطاقه الكهربائيه
لقناتيه العربيه والحدث هذه الصفيان محطه
قطار